oh hey hi welcome to ask IJ where of
course I'm gonna answer all of your
fantastic questions and by answer all of
your questions I actually mean I'm gonna
read your question I'm gonna sort of
answer and it's probably gonna make no
sense to you but I try you got a
question on your mind like mine
there is another way
you can ask my day
Hey whoo thanks to Amy from Carmen music
for that fantastic intro I freaking love
you this is gonna be a two-part ask IJ
episode here the first part I'm gonna
answer all of your Facebook your Twitter
your daily with questions and then when
you're done watching this head over to
iJustine comm where I'm gonna answer all
the questions that you guys asked me
from my website they're on my website
makes completely perfect sense doesn't
it
yep that's so alright let's get to the
questions shall we
Twitter question platicas guitar wants
me to make the oatmeal face from one of
my old videos and if you're not sure of
that video that they're referencing here
it is
yeah I probably can still make the face
let's give it a try
do I like old-school rock like Aerosmith
in Bon Jovi and I noticed you mentioned
Bon Jovi and yes you guys have no idea
my Bon Jovi obsession I freaking love a
Bon Jovi livin on a prayer take my hand
make it I swear
I probably should leave singing up to
mr. John mr. Joby mr. bon bon my
favorite type of tomato happens to be no
tomatoes no not a big fan of tomatoes
except actually I am a huge fan of
ketchup he actually used tomatoes to
make the ketchup I don't like tomatoes
isn't answer your question the honey
badger care yeah don't ever find the
dress that my sister was looking for for
graduation yes we actually did find the
dress and yes she actually did graduate
so congratulations to my sister for
becoming a doctor and here's a picture
of that dress and that's also a picture
of a really fantastic outfit that I
picked out and you probably should not
wear that anywhere ever
Aquagirl what would Steve Jobs do I'm
actually gonna change that around
ww FWD and that stands for what would
Freddie Wong do you tell me what would
Freddie Wong do don't want to know if
I'd rather hang out with the honey
badger or Richard Simmons I'm gonna have
to say mmm
Richard Simmons
instance FML wants to know how I cope
with Playstation being down and actually
I cooked quite well because I mostly
play xbox unless I'm playing a little
big planet please put me in your ass
kept aside comments and now for your
favorite part of a sky Jay it's where I
put you your comments here in my video
all you got to do is leave a comment
below saying Justine please put me in a
future episode of ask IJ or feel free to
make it a little more creative than that
and you guys can see yourself here in a
future episode
here's something last week make the
question right when I was young and did
I use a Mac or a PC what do you guys
think I used a Mac can I make it rain
first of all I'm gonna need to clarify
do you want it to rain like dolla dolla
bills or like precipitation if I could
be any Necromorph from dead space -
which one would I be I would probably be
that stupid one that keeps regrowing his
lids and you just couldn't kill him
found to be a piece of cheese what type
of cheese would I be I would probably be
a non-dairy non-soy piece of cheese what
I have in my fridge what we got in here
cheese
uh pepper jack more cheese that's all
I've ever thought about visiting London
and actually yes I have thought about it
I've thought about it a lot and maybe
one day we'll actually booked myself a
plane ticket and come there and visit
you guys
daily this question oh I like of
tweaking the mustache if I had one I
probably would tweak it mustache no
mustache it's very magical look did I
have a fun time at Richard Simmons
workout class yes I did and here is a
little clip that I pulled off of the
YouTube videos he posted
how old was I when I had my first kiss
hot sex cuz I can't really remember
guess it wasn't that good was it no
Tom's or vans I'm gonna have to deal
with Thomas because I kind of love their
one for one deal and as a matter of fact
I just found out that they have pink
sparkly Tom's and I'm gonna go get
myself a pair tomorrow and maybe the
next day
Kevin favorite episode I like dr. pepper
and I also like Mountain Dew when I also
like Pepsi and I also really really like
cream soda but to be completely honest I
don't really drink soda that often can I
make that face I don't know what song
never fails to cheer me up what I'm
feeling sad any song by Justin Bieber
and I was like baby baby baby oh sunny
sunshine is wondering since I'm so fancy
what type of perfume do I like and
actually I've been using this fancy
bottle of Daisy by Marc Jacobs one
little bit oh you guys smell so nice
sorry lens is all dirty I'm growing a
blanket Jenner murmur my question though
how's the weather in California pretty
nice if hell is hot shouldn't have him
be cold you know cuz it's way up in like
the sky and stuff like I'm just thinking
of Mount Everest and how cold it is up
there so yeah okay since I'm not
actually sure what does question is feel
free to leave me a video response below
if you guys have any questions and don't
forget I take all of your questions from
Facebook from Twitter from dailybooth
and now I've started taking questions
from my website and I just seem calm so
be sure to check out part 2 of that
video over there on my website so we get
to subscribe so you'll know what I
launched a new video and of course check
out the rest of my youtube channels here
wow I just gave you guys like a million
things to do
I suggest go check out part 2 Majesty
now come then come back here check out
these and then don't forget to subscribe
so many little projects so minimal
things to do and just so little time I
will see you guys whenever I see you hi